I don't know what your character model
is shifty eyes mark really maybe three
yes this you just like headfirst dive
bombed into the fan and flew off it was
incredible who killed these people oh
this is bad idea I'll catch it I'll
catch it I'll catch it on can you kill
it really would kill I think wait let's
try that okay try to get right into your
noggin and you shot right missed him
okay we got it I will look up melon
bomber after Hey I found the gun wait
why is the gun over here why couldn't
you pick it up all the way over there
wait got killed by a fan and the gun
flew across the map will you add the gun
way you're just an idiot hello tango
[Laughter]
tango shut up why would I shut up it
happened right to me hey come here
why is Tommy not helping us oh man I
killed him you did right away
God good you are an efficient murderer
I know I'm good you're a little too good
at this okay okay oh there's no way that
mark is a bystander again
the gun
I am a bystander I am innocent
[Laughter]
idiot are you sure about that
yeah I am impressed with my own reflexes
on that one unpossible I died before the
game even started well why we go I got
it I got it I got the mousetrap I got it
okay I got it I got the gun again so you
bastards better watch out you better not
cry you better watch out I'm telling you
why well I see someone's no one I almost
get killed by the mousetrap where'd you
go
what Jojo cute it's so adorable it's
sort of and nope nope nope nope nope
nope
ah you're done now you done son you're
done there's a great follow up to my
great headshot on zombie the wrath round
what can I do to prove my innocence do
you know gotta do baby okay no no I
might I changed my mind
really okay could be like The Walking
Dead thing we could do that again you
know people like that yeah just sayin
desperate here for me to trust you mark
I'm not a murderer oh no why am i blind
I was innocent
if you shoot an innocent person you drop
your gun you better get it back he's
around somewhere
wait is wade with bob is that how this
is I think Yankee is zombie I think I'm
with zombie okay you may want to be
careful I see what's going on down here
[Music]
I was way on top of the on the very top
bookshelf that was another shot oh the
only kill of that time when I was the
murderer wasn't even by me yeah exactly
who's by who did a great shot in my face
or a unit just always got taken out by
the mousetrap mark no not me
hey hey hey hey get away from me Bob I
distracted you I landed on your head
[Music]